Game of Thrones Season 6 episode 10 the
season finale let's have a look we begin
in King's Landing with Cersei and Tommen
and Margaery and the Sparrow suiting up
for the big trial with Sept bells
tolling in the background an ominous
calm before the storm everyone comes to
the Sept the sparrows the Tyrells Lancel
and Kevan Lannister the lords and ladies
of King's Landing though suspiciously
Cersei and Tommen stay at the red cape
the trial begins and Loras submits to
the faith confesses his crimes of
banging Renly and lying about it at
trial and as punishment he has to give
up the Tyrell name which pretty much
ends house Tyrell because while on the
books Loras has brothers the show
version of Loras is apparently the only
heir to their house the sparrows goals
aren't just religious they're political
he's taking down the Great Houses so now
that Tyrells gone he turns to Laster
sending Lancel to go get Cersei Lancel
for some reason decides to follow a boy
into a basement where he gets stabbed
and discovers the Wildfire set to blow
up the Sept meanwhile pycelle is lured
two carbons laboratory where he's killed
by little birds in the books it's not
Qyburn but Varys who does this virus
murders pycelle and Kevin and gives this
cool speech about how is working to
destabilize Westeros to make the
Targaryen invasion easier though in the
books he's sort of supporting a
different Targaryen it's complicated but
the point is that now pycelle is dead
back at the Sept March suspects that
something's up so she tries to evacuate
but it's too late Lancel tries to stop
the wildfire but he's too slow to so
everything blows the [ __ ] up killing the
sparrow and his moment of victory
killing the Tyrells in the moment of
defeat killing Cersei zone uncle Kevan
Lannister and his son Lancel and all
these hundreds or thousands of others
ladies and Lords sparrows small folk
everyone in and around the Sept is
killed by Cersei how can she justify
this terrible crime in the next scene we
see Cersei with Ornella the shame bail
lady and xxx says the reason she killed
all these people is because it felt good
that imagining their shock and pain is
the greatest joy she's ever felt this is
some Ramsay Bolton level evil here
previously when says he did terrible
things she'd usually tell herself that
she did it to protect her kids but here
she's straight-up saying that she kills
people for pleasure
she's turned to the dark side and the
mountain is the Darth Vader to her
Emperor she sends him in to torture who
nella and we get a brief shot of the
mountain unmasked it's hard to see in
the dark but Gregor does pretty much
look like Vader then we see Tommen
watching his city burn he has failed as
a king but letting his people die he has
failed as a husband by letting his wife
Margaery burn he has failed as a
follower of the faith by letting the
sparrow blow up and of course none of
this is really his fault he's always
been a pawn of other players manipulated
by the sparrow by Cersei by Margaery
he's never really done anything of his
own will before so this death is tragic
not only because he was basically a good
kid and that he never knew his real
father and that his family mistreated
him it's tragic that deciding to die is
like the first real choice he's ever
made the joke going around at the moment
is that this is why they call it King's
Landing because the king landed but all
the stuff will probably be very
different in the books for starters the
torment of the books is like 10 years
old these main activities are to play
with these kittens and to try to outlaw
beats book Tommen won't be jumping out
of windows any time soon the way it
might go down in the books is that
Tommen might die some other way then
Cersei will blow up the Wildfire in
response in grief and rage further the
Wildfire in the books probably won't
just blow up the Sept in fact the
Wildfire beneath the Sept was found and
removed but there is still wildfire all
over the city
so maybe it'll be the whole city that
burns down this may happen in the show
too somehow because we still have that
vision of the red cape burned that
hasn't happened yet maybe it'll be
Danny's Dragon Fire that sets it off
anyway over the twins the frozen the
Lannisters celebrate the retaking of
Riverrun Jaime and Bronn chat and then
Walder comes along and says he and Jamie
aren't so different you and I they're
both kingslayer's Walder killed King
Robb Stark at the red wedding and Jaime
killed King Aerys Targaryen during
Robert's rebellion 20 years ago
both Walder and Jaime are heated for
these dishonorable killings though what
Walder doesn't know is that Jaime killed
the Mad King for a good reason to stop
air is blowing up King's Landing with
wildfire bit like what Cersei just did
Jaime doesn't want to be like Walden he
increasingly tries to be a good
honorable person so it'll be interesting
to see how he reacts to Circe's wildfire
attack
circe sees the dead body of her last
child and it's just like the gypsy woman
said
Maggy the Frog prophesied that all
Circe's children would die gold their
crowns and gold their shrouds and it all
came true so maybe the reason so she
takes the death of her son so calmly is
that she already knew it was going to
happen she'd already grieved and now
she's numb empty with nothing left in
the world to give her joy except the
suffering of her enemies another part of
the prophecy in the books is that Cersei
will be replaced by a younger and more
beautiful Queen Cersei thought this was
Margaery but it's probably going to be
Danny in the rage salmon Gilly arrived
at the city of Old Town that lighthouse
there is called the high tower they're
not creative with names here they go to
the Citadel home of the maesters they
deal with some annoying bureaucrat and
then Sam's led into the library reading
is one of Sam's few loves and this is
the biggest library in Westeros maybe in
the world so this is a dream come true
for Samwell Tarly
of course it'll also be important to the
plot maybe Sam will find some book about
White Walkers or Azure a high or
Valyrian steel something that could help
the humans win the war against the
walkers also that Astra lady Thiang of
the ceiling is the thing from the intro
of the show showing the history of
Westeros but yea while Sam is reading
it's not clear what Gilly and her baby
will do because the Citadel doesn't
accept women and children in the books
there's heaps of other stuff going on at
Old Town like the faceless man jaqen
H'ghar arrives disguised as an alchemist
to steal a book and one of the sand
snakes comes disguised as a man to study
and later Ironborn Raiders on a Euron
arrive and there's also this enigmatic
maester called Marwan the mage doing
some spooky magic stuff he might be the
archmaester this guy mentions so we
don't know how much of this will make it
into this show but there's certainly
lots of cool content to draw from the
books one likely conflict in the show is
that Sam's father Randall may come for
his Valyrian steel sword heart's pain
which we say Sam still has up at
Winterfell John complains to Mel about
having to sit at the back at family
faced s-- Mel tells him to check his
privilege Jay grew up as a slave at
least in the books she's still haunted
by nightmares of a childhood and her
original name by the way was Melanie
then Davos arrives and confronts Mel
about the murder of Shireen Mel admits
that she did it admits it was wrong but
argues that Jon should keep her anyway
because she'll be
useful in the war against the walkers
which is a really good point Mel is one
of the only people who seems to know
what the deal is with the war for the
dawn and azor Ahai and all that but
regardless john decides to exile mel
orders her to ride south which could go
some interesting ways at the same time
Mel heads south the Brotherhood without
banners is heading north Thoris is a red
priest like Mel and in the show they've
met before so maybe they'll catch up
talk about their God and John's
resurrection and stuff Brienne and pod
are also heading north and they get
caught up with a Brotherhood in the
books and I is also around when Mel
meets her in season 3 she says they'll
meet again so all of these characters
could somehow be involved in whatever
comes next for Melisandre Jon and Sansa
talk and she apologizes for not telling
Jon about the Knights of the Vale before
the Battle of the bastards though she
doesn't explain why she didn't tell him
even though it was kind of a big deal
strategically but he accepts her apology
of course he should be apologizing to he
almost got everyone killed by writing
into the middle of the battle instead of
sticking to the plan with trenches so
really both Sansa and Jon were pretty
damned last episode the point of this
scene though is to show some tension and
uneasiness between Jon and Sansa it's
not certain if they trust each other
which could lead to conflict next season
also white Raven arrives to signify that
winter has finally officially come and
it only took six seasons Olenna Tyrell
comes to dawn she wants revenge on
Cersei for killing her family so she
allies with the sand snakes who also
hate the Lannisters for the deaths of
Oberyn and earlier then Varys walks in
representing Daenerys and they form a
powerful three-way alliance between
Targaryen Tyrell and Martell of course
the sand snakes aren't really Martel's
they're illegitimate bastards who
murdered the rightful Lord durin Martell
and Elena isn't really a Tyrell she's a
red wine who married a Tyrell so she
probably shouldn't be in power either
the politics here don't strictly really
make a whole lot of sense but the
overall idea of the Alliance is cool and
sets the stage for Daenerys to invade in
Mereen Daenerys breaks up with Daario
she can't bring a lover to Westeros
because politically she needs to be open
for marriage Daario is to stay and keep
the peace in Mehreen which is probably a
really bad idea
Daario is a random mercenary he doesn't
know how to govern and he doesn't care
about marine and the situation here is
still far from
a Danny has banned slavery and cost down
the Masters but there's no new social
system to take its place the sons of the
harpy are still out there and the freed
slaves still need protection
but Daenerys decides to declare mission
accomplished and roll on out anyway she
renamed slavers Bay to the bay of
dragons which is cool but you could call
North Korea freedom land and that
wouldn't make it true conquering a
foreign land destroying the existing
social structure then leaving can have
very bad results one of the major themes
from the books is the messiness and
moral complexity of war and for the show
to capture this it should revisit marine
later to show us the chaos Danny's
leaving behind her on a lighter note who
are the eligible bachelors of Westeros
who Downey might marry maybe Jamie now
that he's been released from his
Kingsguard vows he's presumably their
heir to House Lannister and all its
power and Jaime might not be so keen on
Cersei now that she's a mass murderer
and also maybe Daniel hook up with
golden hand only catch might be then he
killed her dad a better candidate could
be John as the king in the north he
controls a huge chunk of Westeros he's
also supposedly azor Ahai the prophesied
savior of the world just as she is
and he kind of represents ice in the
same way Dany represents fire and the
book series is called A Song of Ice and
Fire so basically John and Danny could
make a hell of a power couple the only
reason why probably won't happen is that
it almost feels too obvious Danny talks
with Tyrion and he swears himself to her
service seems truly devoted to a cause
which seems kind of Sodom almost out of
character Tyrion is hardly the kneeling
type and in the books he's very cynical
about this whole Targaryen restoration
business but it does kind of make sense
that it be drawn to Dany Tyrians just
lost his family and his lover is far
from home what he needs now is purpose
and back in Westeros that was politics
being hand of the king made him feel
valuable and important so when Daenerys
makes him her hand that's exactly what
Tyrion needs same goes for a lot of
Danny's followers she draws all these
misfits and exiles and broken men to her
people who need a flag to follow
something to believe in
she offers them hope for a brighter
future so they fight for her and
historically that's never gone badly
right then we see I infiltrate the twins
disguised with the face of a serving
girl she makes a pie out of black Walder
and Luther Frey and feeds
to their own father Walda who she then
kills to avenge the deaths of her mother
and brother of the red wedding fans have
pointed out the three men who arranged
the red wedding Walder Frey Tywin
Lannister and Roose Bolton are killed in
the same way their victims are Walder
has his throat slashed like Catelyn
Tywin is shot with a crossbow like Rob
and Roose is stabbed in the gut just
like tallousa so there's a cool cemetary
there but yeah ayuh has made another
kill she watches and smiles as the man
befall her dies and it'll be interesting
to see how the show plays is arc in the
future like we meant to cheer as this
child dedicates her life to a murder
spree or should we question whether
violent vengeance is the only answer but
for now there are still targets left on
Aya's list she's killed polliver Meryn
Trant and now Walder Frey but they're
still Cersei and Gregor Clegane so maybe
I will go after them but there were
others who were on her list temporarily
the hound for killing Micah
Berek and Thoros and Melisandre for
betraying Gendry and these guys are
currently in and around the Riverlands
so maybe something will happen with them
back at Winterfell Sansa meets with
Littlefinger in the same spot Ned and
cat meet in season 1 Littlefinger says
these ultimate goal is to become the
king of Westeros with Sansa at his side
which pretty much fits with what we've
seen of him so far he's always been
hungry for power and he's always wanted
Sansa mostly because she reminds him of
her mom who Littlefinger loved but Sansa
rejects him she knows that he's only
really out for himself but she also
doesn't move against him which she
probably could and should because little
fingers a seriously bad dude right he
killed Sansa's aunt Lysa he betrayed Ned
Stark he caused the War of the five
kings by turning the Lannisters against
the Starks he even helped kill King
Joffrey for that's worth Littlefinger is
dangerous and he's worked against the
Starks and as the lady of Winterfell
Sansa's in a position to take him down
she could tell the Knights of the Vale
that Littlefinger killed their lady Lysa
and lied about the Bolton's she could
tell the Lords of the north that
Littlefinger betrayed their Lord Ned
Stark though we don't know how much
Sansa knows about that either way Sansa
totally could get Littlefinger
imprisoned or executed for his crimes
which would make everybody much safer
but she doesn't she lets him go so while
Sansa doesn't team up with Littlefinger
here she leaves that door open keeps him
as a possible ally in the future which
could be really useful but it could also
go very badly because the census has
herself on
a fool would trust Littlefinger beyond
the wall benjin drops off bran and Mira
by a weirwood tree the same tree John
and Sam swear the Nights Watch vows out
in season one benjin says he can't take
them through the wall itself because the
wall has magic that stops on these like
him from going through which is the same
deal as the book character Colton's the
worrying thing is that these spells that
protect the wall are probably the magic
of the children of the forest the same
kind of magic the protected blood Ravens
cave until that magic was broken by the
night king psychic connection to bran
and that marki made in Episode five
maybe the magic of the wall could be
broken in some similar way
so anyway benjin leaves says he'll do
what he can to fight the White Walkers
and brown tones to the weirwood tree
says that he's the three-eyed Raven now
and again we don't know exactly what
that means but it involves these visions
that he has through weirwood trees and
then we get one of the most anticipated
moments in the series bran has a vision
of the birth of Jon Snow we see a young
Ned Stark at the Tower of joy seeing his
sister Lyanna in a bed of blood just
having given birth to Jon this finally
proves that Jon is not the bastard son
of Ned and some unknown woman but it's
actually the son of his sister Lyanna
the episode doesn't make clear who the
father is but we know from hints in the
books and the show and from a frankly
confusing graph from HBO that the father
of Jon Snow is Rhaegar Targaryen Rhaegar
hasn't appeared in the show but
basically he's the older brother of
Daenerys and the son of the Mad King
Aerys some 20 years before the story
starts Rhaegar ran off with Lyanna Stark
and this started Robert's rebellion the
war that killed Aerys and Rhaegar and
made Robert the king of Westeros Robert
hated Targaryen he wanted to kill them
all and that's why John had to be hidden
as the son of Rhaegar John is hotdog
Arian so Ned had to lie and say John was
his bastard in order to protect him from
Robert that's what lianna is talking
about here but yeah the point of all
this is that John is the son of a stark
in a Targaryen of Ice and Fire he's the
grandson of the Mad King and the nephew
of Daenerys which makes this potential
hookup kind of awkward but this could
have some huge implications this means
that John could have a claim on the Iron
Throne he is still a bastard if Liana
and Rhaegar weren't married but there
are theories that they could have had a
secret wedding maybe bran could have a
vision of that further as a Targaryen
John might
able to ride dragons like Daenerys he
might be fireproof like Daenerys except
there was that one time he got burned
the pole fireproof thing is confusing in
the show but another big thing is that
Ozora high that Hiro prophesied to save
the world from darkness is apparently
meant to be from arrises Lian
so John now fits another part of this
prophecy also we see Ned lien Arthur
Danes famous sword called dawn against
Lee Anna's bed which kind of connects to
another part of the azure Ahai prophecy
saying that azor Ahai will be reborn
beneath a bleeding star dawn is loosely
connected with stars and it's literally
covered in blood so yeah basically this
is more evidence that Jon may be Game of
Thrones Jesus the real question is how
John and the rest of Westeros will find
out about his parentage bran could tell
Jon but the rest of Westeros will want
proof before they let him sit the Iron
Throne or whatever and there are a few
ways this could happen maybe Howland
Reed the other survivor of the Tower of
joy could turn up maybe there's some
kind of secret hidden still in the
Winterfell crypts we'll have to wait and
see but at least now we know the truth
that jon is a son of Ice and Fire
at Winterfell the northern Lords
declared Jon the king in the north the
White Wolf
just as Robb Stark was the young wolf
and this is super cool though it doesn't
make much political sense like sure jon
was brave at the Battle of the bastards
but he's also a deserter of the Nights
Watch which is punishable by death and
he let wobbling through the wall which
most of the north hates and he's a
bastard not the Lord of Winterfell Sansa
is the rightful ruler and half these
lords weren't even at the battle they've
never met Jon before so while they will
love him and trust him so much if Jon
becomes king in the north in the books
it'll happen a very different way
there's this whole thing with Robb
naming Jon his heir as king then sending
mage Mormont and galbart Glover at
Howland Reed so maybe in the books those
guys will turn up and reveal probz
wishes it's probably feather the show
simplifies this though the point is that
Jon now rules a huge chunk of Westeros
apparently including the veil because
Littlefinger says he has sworn to house
Stark
but of course we know not to trust
Littlefinger you want Sansa not Jon in
charge in the north so we'll likely see
some conflict between these guys next
season Littlefinger may try to turn
Sansa against Jon then Jaime returns to
King's Landing Elektro and community and
this is definitely the darkest timeline
surcease it's the Iron Throne
crowns herself the ruler of Westeros
while her city still burns in the
background she's gone full evil queen
here this is some Dark Lord [ __ ] she's
not the rightful ruler
she's a dictator who seized power by
blowing up everyone else maybe you could
call that right of conquest but this is
not a stable regime the people will hate
her because she just blew up the
equivalent of the Vatican she has no
allies or army as far as we know and the
Tyrells Martel's and Targaryen allied
against her
so this reign of terror probably won't
last long the interesting drama will be
Jaime's response he'll be having
flashbacks to Aerys the Mad King he
killed to protect the people if Jaime is
to become this better person he's trying
to be maybe he'll have to kill his
lifelong lover this terrible new Mad
Queen which would by the way fulfill
another part of this prophecy that
Cersei would be killed by her Vallon kua
or little brother the episode ends with
another much anticipated moment Daenerys
Targaryen finally sails for Westeros
with a huge fleet full of unsullied and
Dothraki and Ironborn not to mention
three dragons she's also got Varys and
Tyrells and Martell ships so this must
be months after the rest of the episode
because of the travel time but side note
this is the first time we've seen Varys
and Daenerys together and they actually
have a lot to talk about because Varys
has been [ __ ] with Daenerys as life
for years his scheming with Illyria led
to Danny's marriage with Khal Drogo
Varys informed on day 2 the small
council and ordered an assassination
attempt on at once and Danny does know
this even in the show so she should have
some tough questions for the eunuch
another little thing is that it's kind
of weird to say the Dothraki so
comfortable at sea when it's kind of a
thing that they're terrible sailors
maybe that'll come up later but this is
a great way to end the season Daenerys
is finally set to take the throne so
let's look at the situation at the end
of the season on the Iron Throne
you've got Cersei Lannister with Chi
bone and the mountain at her side Jaime
is there too and he might do something
to stop her allied against Cersei are
the Tyrells under Elena and Dawn under
the sand snakes who was supporting
Daenerys Targaryen sailing in from the
east with Tyrion and Varys in missandei
and gray home and Yara and Theon
an army the king of the Iron Islands is
euron greyjoy
and he'll probably be a big bad guy next
season remember he wants to kill Yara
and Theon marry Dany and take over the
world and in the books he has these
schemes involving black magic and
Dragons
Jon Snow is the king in the north
supported by the northern houses and by
torments wildlings while Sansa is
apparently still the lady of Winterfell
the North is supposedly supported by the
Vale ruled in name by Robert Arryn but
in practice by Littlefinger who will
probably also be a big baddie next
season it's not clear who rules the
Riverlands now that Walder Frey is dead
but Edmure Tully is still alive so maybe
his power could eventually be restored
for now you've got barek Thoreau's the
Hound Brienne plod and Arya all in the
Riverlands with Melisandre coming in
from the north so all sorts of stuff
could happen around there down south Sam
and Gilly are in Old Town and Randall
and decon might come for them over an
SOS marine is left to Dario and the sons
of the harpy and presumably kin Varro
and the red priests are still there kind
of weird they didn't do much this season
Jorah is wandering around esos somewhere
looking for a cure for his greyscale
Gendry is still rolling around somewhere
as well presumably we might also see ty
CONUS taurus again remember the crown
owes a bunch of money to the iron bank
but of course the biggest threat of all
is posed by the White Walkers up in the
north with their army of the Dead
dolorous EDD and the wall probably can't
stop them on their own milk and benjin
so Brandon Mirror better get south soon
the big conflicts next season will
probably be Danny's invasion against
Cersei and maybe Euron there'll be stuff
in the north between John and Sancho and
Littlefinger
but above all there'll be the war for
the dawn between the White Walkers and
everyone else there are just two short
seasons of Game of Thrones left like 13
hours of content this is the beginning
of the end
so Game of Thrones season 6 is done but
there is still so much Thrones left to
talk about where theories and analysis
of characters and plot and predictions
and speculation about the future of the
series and heaps of stuff in the books
that doesn't even appear in the show so
this is the kind of content you'll be
saying from alt shift X when we return
in August we're taking a break for a
while the patreon will be paused so no
one will be charged for July but make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss
future videos if you'd like to be
notified
the moment videos come out you can press
the bell button on the old shift X
channel on the YouTube app on your phone
also if you haven't read the books now
is a really good time to start the books
are everything you love about the game
of Thrones show but more more detailed
more depth more complexity more drama
more politics more mysteries more magic
so many extra little connections and
relationships and backstories and side
characters and histories the books are
amazing they're not the easiest read
they are dense and complex and very
bloody long but if you can get into them
you'll really enjoy them so there's a
link in the description to buy the books
it's an Amazon link that supports the
channel if you use it at no extra cost
to you otherwise you can find the books
by other ways online if you've already
read the books and you want to go deeper
down the rabbit hole go check out the
Game of Thrones forums like the Song of
Ice and Fire subreddit and Westeros dog
many of the ideas and theories discussed
on this channel come from those forums
also the podcasts there are heaps of
great game of Thrones podcasts two of
the biggest and best are Radio Westeros
and history of Westeros really in-depth
analysis of story themes theories
predictions so go and check em out
between the podcasts and the forums and
the books on this channel there is
plenty of thorns content to last until
next season and if we're lucky we might
even get a new book soon so thank you
for watching thank you for commenting
and liking and subscribing and thank you
for the emails and tweets and messages
so I'm sorry I can't reply to them all
but the support is really sweet
thanks for the caption translators who
have been making captions available in
dozens of languages and the biggest of
thanks goes to the patrons on patreon
this season six explain series doing a
video every week would have been totally
impossible without your support this
channels come a long way from where it
was a year ago thanks to you patrons in
fact one of the things we're doing now
is we're looking for a production
assistant to help make videos faster so
if you're good with After Effects and
you know Game of Thrones well and you're
free for some production work especially
during season seven please click on the
link to the google form below to apply
shout out to patrons Jason a jig mule
Reverend xandria mr. fee for a say
Cameron Weiss David Hale Vanya Dawg Eric
louis-dreyfus Jason pan Eric Kuykendall
scene Bobby Jo Kate lines Ryan Steele
Michael Appel Brandon L stags Jason
Rattray Fallon M Craig Riley Sean ludka
Todd Marcus Chris Cole Jake Berlin
emotion Matthew Elijah Williams for at
Betty my rains a day Kevin Donahue sandy
breath extra mustard Ferguson Jory
strack new Ram Roop and Ricky mint thank
you all for your support see you in
August
you